conduct company at here and less reliant
on like folks like me going out solving
problems in the field
that was really where i also got a lot
of exposure to working with engineering
and product teams including my
co-founders and other people i work with
now
um
and saying like well hey let's
understand the problems people are
trying to solve with data and then build
build tools um
build tools for our clients to be able
to do those things
and so i i would never call myself a
proper developer although i feel like i
got a lot more technical at volunteer
across a lot of different parts of the
stack
but um i felt very proud of sort of
being able to contribute to a lot of the
products we wanted building and and
deploying to our customers and users
so
and and so and what form did these tools
like manifest themselves in were these
still i mean i assume it's a little bit
less than a hacky excel spreadsheet or
model or excel excel app if you will did
you just excel at marketplace or what
did you build
no i mean
pounds here um
you know go to a lot of detail on this
but
you know we had our government platform
which is called gotham and and then we
were the time i was there was sort of
renaissance in terms of building out a
more what i would call widely applicable
commercial platform
it's sort of it's called foundry i mean
there's now a bunch of stuff on it on
the console website but
it's kind of end-to-end all-in-one data
integration and analysis platform that's
it's actually very cool and there's a
lot of ideas in there that we
worked on you know years ago that now
you kind of see in this campground
explosion of data tools you know um
around data integration and quality and
elt and all that
but i think one the probably the most
interesting thing um and the key thing
at bouncers across the business on
almost everything we did
i would say the consistent thing was
focusing
on unlocking the potential of this
really big population of analytical
people who don't necessarily have cs
degrees or even like formal data
training and so you think about a lot of
the core user personas um for palantir's
products there's like the intelligence
analyst in the government side or
someone on the factory floor building
airplanes on the commercial side or
uh
you know a marine downrange
these are people for whom
um
they need things from their data they
and and they want to do more with data
but they're not like a data scientist
like none of these people are just going
to like fire up a jupiter notebook
locally to go like explore some data
and so i think the consistent thing at
talent here and the thing i loved
was building tools to empower them and
unlock the potential of their data and
um i think when you're
when you're in startups when you're in
tech when you're in this you know data
space if you live in sf or new york or
you know whatever it's easy to sort of
feel like you're in that bubble of like
you know if you've worked at one of
these big companies you know uber or
facebook or whatever
um
it's easy to think that the whole world
looks like that like
like
but it doesn't and there's
millions and millions of people
all over the world who
are doing things with data they're sharp
they're data driven they're analytical
and they're held back by not having the
right tools and they're not the people
that maybe have the training or
credentials to go work at one of these
big tech companies that can build a lot
of their own stuff where everyone's
really technical and so that was always
the interesting thing to me at palantir
was like how do you meet those people
where they are but also like
treat them like the really smart
motivated
people that they are and build a
platform that empowers and unlocks them
and i thought that was when i look back
on a lot of the work we did that that's
what i'm probably the proudest of
um and it's almost like building the
platforms that can get them out of that
hacky excel world like you'd be shocked
at how many like really critical
workflows in the world across commercial
and government are done through
like hacking excel stuff you know like
um in a lot of ways we were trying to
build the like really productized
amazing alternatives to those
um those things
and and do you what do you feel is the
lowest common denominator
um for sort of technical proficiency
to really like you know
bring these folks onto a meaningful data
platform like do you have a
sql belief do you have a
python belief do you wait was it sort of
even lower lower than
than those um in terms of sort of less
common denominator like what what's the
mean what's the minimum skill level you
believe these
smart analysts who are not truly
technical
like need to sort of like for us you
know us as a technical community to
embrace them like what does that look
like
i don't have a lot of um
religion around languages
like i i think you can certainly talk
about different languages as being like
more accessible like sql is pretty
pretty accessible in its own way
i think what's interesting is just like
looking at the span of my career
um you know there's there's a lot of our
users at holland here that um you know
didn't know didn't know sql they're
probably capable of learning sql but
maybe that wasn't even the best workflow
for them and what they were doing you
know
um there's a lot of like visual graph
based workflows that we build adult
pounds or to help people do
investigations and stuff where like even
writing sequel for that would have been
clunky because that was an easy thing to
do um
i think the way we look at it now and
we'll probably talk more about this in
the context of hex is like we're big
believers in this population that we
call the like analytically technical
and and these are people who as i
mentioned earlier they don't have a cs
degree they don't have a
data science background but they're
sharp they work with data they're
curious they're trying to solve problems
through data
and i think the span of this i usually
draw is like anywhere from your like
really proficient excel user up to
you know a
true proper data scientist machine
learning engineer like
this is a
span that is
big and growing really fast
and i think that a lot of the things we
think about as a company are like how do
we build the tools to let them do their
best work so i think of a little bit
less of like a language
uh specific thing and and i think these
people can show up in a lot of different
ways
got it
great
um so from valencia you went to trial
spark and
yeah what what was the nature of your
role there what did you learn there um
about data that that sort of shaped your
current thinking
yeah well i i had a great few years at
pounds here um i felt like i learned a
lot and just wanted a different shape of
a challenge and to do something
different so i went to charles sparks
it's a healthcare startup um focused on
clinical trials which was an area i
thought was really cool and wanted to
learn more about i was in a pretty
operational role
um
uh which was interesting
and the mission of the company was
really like improving clinical trials
through better technology and data and
so i really liked that idea of like
taking this kind of hard real world
problem and trying to apply technology
and data installed but i feel very
congruent with a lot of the things i've
been doing
and the interesting thing about clinical
trials is that they're all about data
it may not be obvious when you think
about it but the whole point of a
clinical trial is producing a data set
that can tell you something about the
safety or efficacy of a given drug or
intervention that you're studying
and obviously this is really in the news
now like literally right now you know
this week
but even you know the last couple of
years with covant of like all these
clinical trials we're all waiting on
baited breath you know what you're
waiting for is really the data to come
out and the data to be analyzed and what
you learn from that data path
and so i you know that's a really
interesting frame as i got to know the
company and what they were doing that i
thought that was such an interesting
thing and there's a lot of opportunities
when you think about the way clinical
trials are run
to improve them through through
technology and data
um and so i came in in this sort of
operational role
um i worked really closely with our tech
and data teams
um
and it was really interesting because i
saw a lot of the same pain points pop up
that i feel like i had seen
sort of throughout my career to date in
terms of um
collaboration and sharing we had this
amazing really sharp data team we had an
operation
that was really hungry to try to power
our work and and inform our work through
data
um and we had a pretty modern data stack
we had we're using like stitch redshift
we were really early adopters of dbt we
had blocker but our data scientists were
and analysts were really spending a lot
of their time in like random sql ids or
local jupiter notebooks
and they were doing really cool work but
their ability to share both to
collaborate within the team but then to
share with the rest of the organization
was super limited and so i found that
super frustrating having coming from a
few years at
um
talent here building
you know software i was sort of like wow
there has to be a product to like help
solve this and so i actually started
this journey as a of hex as the buyer
like i was looking for a product that i
felt like could help solve this pain we
had around collaboration and sharing
around our data work
um
and
and helping the you know these really
brilliant people we had to do more and
be more impactful and so that was um
that was pretty formative for me in
terms of just like both seeing the sort
of modern data stack emerge but seeing
those gaps
and
and um yeah i think it took me a couple
of months of like shopping basically
like of like looking at a lot of
different stuff and trying to cobble
together a bunch of open source things
to kind of be convinced like man there
really is like a
uh thing to be built here
and what sort of open source things did
you cobble together i'm curious
well
you know i think when you look at the
data
ecosystem and the
you know the ecosystem around things
like jupiter there's a lot of cool open
source things people have built like i
you know there's a lot of creativity and
a lot of
neat things in that space
um
and we tried a bunch of them you know we
were hosting our own jupiter hub thing
we had a bunch of extensions on it and
then we tried you know a bunch of these
things around being able to sort of
share your work in different ways
there's some really interesting projects
that come out of big companies like
airbnb there's there's other stuff just
in the community
and like these things are all cool cool
and good ideas and they work in their
own way i think the lived experience of
them though was a little
uh greedy like
you know like it's one thing for like me
or other people on the data team or
certain engineers to be able to like run
this stuff and understand it the
overhead of maintaining it was really
high and certainly the overhead of
trying to get anyone like not really
fluent in this stuff to be able to get
any value from it was was just not worth
the squeeze i mean i remember going
around and installing
python like getting python environments
set up on one of our sales people's
laptops so she could run something and
it was like i just remember being like
this is not how this should work right
so i don't want to like drag on any open
certified they're all like beautiful
projects it was more just like hey like
we were trying to cobble a lot of it
together in a way that
to kind of form a product
in a way that that just didn't didn't
really work for us
got it
so so this is the key insight that that
drove you to start yeah i mean i i love
it when it's sort of so obvious in a
person's career and they're the sequence
of their experience that
um they've they've basically lived out
um their own pain and get to this
insight this key insight that really
like inspires the birth of the company
and it sounds like
um you had that moment and and and and
that's what led to start hux
yeah and a lot of those moments you know
we just talked through my the sort of
span of my
career today and it's like i think kind
of every one of those those times
in every one of those roles there were
moments where i feel like i
i wanted something like tax and and it
wasn't always obvious in the moment like
it was not like i was in consulting and
being like no i started a company around
this other day but you know looking back
sort of like it all sort of was forming
that primordial scoop that i think
sort of kicked this off so
so yeah i mentioned you know i started
this journey kind of as like a buyer a
user a
practitioner
um
and it took me a while i think to
convince myself you know this is true
with a lot of ideas i think of like am i
the only one am i am i crazy is there
some product out here that does this
really well that i'm just not seeing
um and i think it fundamentally was
around collaboration and sharing um
that consistent pain point and
reflecting on
all those experiences with data that was
a consistent pain point you know i
mentioned like doing this crazy stuff in
excel like trying to ship that data
product to others version control and
iterate
and get other people to be able to use
this crazy product develop was really
painful collaboration was really cool a
lot of things worked out at valencia and
certainly that was the point
in my role
with the david team at charles park so
um i think that
that was really the key insight of like
this is a this is a world that this data
space is the world that i think needs
better tooling around collaboration
engineering
i mean there's also something there
about access like
if only a small population of people can
work with these tools
you're really going to limit
your scope and impact
um
and that was another thing that i feel
like i took away um especially from my
last experience was
you know if you only have two or three
people who can really go do meaningful
work with data you're really limiting
what
what you the the impact that data can
have in your organization
yeah right
so
just from a structural company building
standpoint um how did you decide who you
wanted to work with to start the company
and how did you find them
well
i was very fortunate to work with
some truly brilliant people in my career
and certainly during my time at
volunteer
is where i met both of my co-founders
glenn
takahashi was my intern in 2014 and we
built a very happy product together at
the time um and he and i had been
working together kind of ever since like
we worked together off and on about here
and then he um he actually came
to charles park i mean so we worked
together there he was doing a lot of
engineering and data engineering there
and he and i actually saw
he was one of the first people i talked
to about this stuff i was like hey like
this all feels really sub-optimal right
like the way we're doing this and and he
and i just started getting in a
you know mode of jamming about that sort
of dreaming about it
and you know one thing led to another
and then as we were progressing on that
and it sort of went from this kind of
kind of sucks to like well what if we
built a thing for this um as that got
more serious uh i got back in touch with
caitlin colgrove who had also worked
with collins here who
you know was brilliant a really amazing
engineer and an engineering leader
and she was like the first and really
only person that we wanted to be um
co-founder and cto
and so the three of us started started
talking about this and you know it takes
a while to like go from oh that's a cool
idea that like i'm gonna quit my job and
do this
but over the course of a few months we
all got there and it was almost two
years ago now that we we sort of um
sort of congealed and gotten going on it
but um
one thing i think every
everyone has been working for long
enough can probably identify with in
some way like you don't realize in the
moment
how
uh
the people you meet and you work with
and you
will will
have an impact on your life whether it's
you know just a networking point or
someone you want to start a company with
like that's
i i think
a piece of advice i'll give to other
people career-wise is like just go
places where you can work with really
great people like that will pay
dividends in ways you will never
understand and i'm certainly the
beneficiary of that in working with both
of them they're they're fabulous people
yeah that's awesome
so so early days of hex you had sort of
faced the pain of collaboration data
collaboration yourself through a couple
different roles how did you figure out
if
there was a big enough market for
for this and like how did you test other
custom potential customers and get that
early feedback to kind of prove to you
that
um this is a big
big enough thing to pursue
i think early on like one of the first
things that's always tough to get over
is like that why hasn't everyone done
this before or am i crazy am i the only
person seeing us
and it took a couple months and so um we
spend a lot of time asking other people
we knew in the data community um glenn
and i were both in new york city at the
time and so i kind of bounced around new
york i remember visiting various friends
that are on data teams or that worked
with data teams
visiting their offices and this is
before we you know quit we were just
kind of on the side sniffing around this
and
uh spent a lot of time asking you know
hey do you have a similar problem seeing
going on site seeing what they were
doing
um
and it took a while i think to figure
out the patterns between where it was
and wasn't the pinpoint
um
uh you know what phase of maturity of a
company or a data team or the types of
problems or workflows are they doing
that um
that made this but it was a couple
months of doing that and i remember
visiting one friend in particular in new
york and like
it was uncanny how much their workflow
looked the same as ours and the pain
points were looked the same as ours it's
a really common archetype we see today
as well with new customers coming out
hacks is like
they're like using the local notebook or
they're using some id somewhere and like
their workflow is like yeah well it's
like share this i like screenshot the
chart and paste it into a google
developer i like export the csv and i
put it in a google sheet or i
render it as a static html file and put
it in slack like that is just so common
and i remember seeing that like two or
three times in the course of the month
as we were bouncing around and being
like okay like there clearly is some sub
optionality here and if someone has
solved this
we're not seeing it um and and i think
seeing enough of those was was really
confidence building that there's
something here we may not know the exact
shape of what we're gonna go but there's
something here to explore
and so that was the original
i mean as i recall that that was very
early product features in hex2 it was
like the share it was like the publisher
the share you know we talk about
collaboration which could include other
things
maybe many things and we can talk about
that but i i distinctly remember just
this export you know export like graph
and sort of share it in an efficient way
in a digitally like native way like that
was a thing and that was like one of the
early edges of the hex products i recall
that's right and
early on in fact we you know we even
thought
and
toyed with the idea of even building
like a thinner sort of like just last
mile thing like we actually kind of
assumed at different points that people
might edit or create their their work
somewhere else like they'll like use a
jupyter notebook and then
export an ipy and then upload it and
then build the app in hex
um
and so yeah that was some of the first
features we built was around that sort
of like publishing and sharing
paradigm
the
interesting thing there was like as we
and then it's just you know you're
asking about validating the idea and
it's like the natural way startups sort
of evolve i think is like as we were
going out and testing that in the field
with with users
we did hear though like they were like
oh yeah but like they were telling us
about all the rest of their pain with
both their like single player experience
of building and working on these
projects and then like collaborating
and that's where that's where we started
getting pulled i think by our users and
early customers into that bigger scope
of doing this
more end to end and building that
platform and i think over time there was
just this series of things where we're
great well let's experiment with that
let's build that feature let's try that
let's see if we can get
validate that
um and that sort of bigger thing started
to really open up for us
um and so we kind of started from that
sharing and but it's really obviously
covered up a lot more ground since then
got it
um well i want you to tell us about what
hex is and what hex does since we've
sort of like poked around the edges but
but before we do that um
i like to ask about like your product
values and sort of your product
philosophy and because sometimes i think
that provides helpful context for
additional context and really
understanding what makes you tick and
before you tell us sort of like what the
product actually does
um you know to better understand sort of
why you built it the way you did and and
sort of what design principles you
walked into the the problem with um i
think would be really interesting
totally well a couple
you know we we kind of have three core
product pillars that we talk about
internally um one is
low floor and height ceiling and what
that means is a product that is
accessible easy for sort of the let's
call it the lower end of that
analytically technical population in
terms of their raw technical skills to
come in and actually do productive work
but a high ceiling that does an
arbitrary level of people i think when
you look at some existing tools
uh on some of the landscape you see a
lot of like fragmentation where it's
like yeah like this tool does
point-and-click no code things and this
tool is where i can write some simple
logic in something and then i use this
tool when i'm writing like sql and then
i jump over to this tool if i need to do
anything in python that's like it
the fragmentation is as painful as an
individual it's painful as a team
and so we have that low floor high
ceiling philosophy was like we actually
believe that
you can't be everything to everyone but
we believe there's a span where we want
to build the best platform for the
people in that uh in that world to both
work themselves and collaborate with you
on that note you know we talk about
collaboration and teamwork
um i i've talked a lot about that just
now it was sort of
pain and inspiration um for hexan
that's obviously very core value hex is
a deeply collaborative platform both
you know you and i being able to
collaborate on a project together but
then being able to share communicative
so that's um
that's another big product pillar
for us and then i think there's like a
thing too just over everything we built
that really caring about design and
quality as a first class concern um
you know we
want to be part of the work and we
wanted to alert our users and
um who are using the product
and so that's that's another thing we
think a lot about
well i have to say the the design of the
product is something that's been
attractive to me since um the time i
first first first fell in love um so i
think it i think it shows that
corvette and engineering teams on that
one yeah yeah awesome
yeah
well so so tell us like what hex does
and who hex is for um so we understand
the base total case
so hex is a
we call it a data workspace it's um a
platform that allows
people in this analytically technical
population whether they're a data
analyst or data scientist or analytics
engineer or whatever they call
themselves to connect the data
query explore analyze
and then share and um
you know we think of it as not just as
you know a notebook
thing or whatever you know
and there's we have a notebook paradigm
and obviously there's a lot there but
like
we kind of see this as a much bigger
sort of end-to-end platform for being
able to
do go from exploratory data work to
something that's actually useful and
impactful into in an organization
and so when you ask who is it for you
know we want to appeal to that entire
span of the analytically technical
and i think there's an obvious
first persona
at a lot of customers which is like a
you know
nominal data scientist who might already
be using python or using notebooks
that's it that's kind of an obvious like
first adopter at a lot of customers but
it really fans out quite broadly from
that and i think what we see that's
really interesting is there's a lot of
people in just data analyst roles
people who
um
maybe never would have fired up a local
jupiter notebook or or have never done
that or they find that really
intimidating because they have to go
learn python enter manage an environment
and even further we see people that are
product managers marketers sales people
it's really really interesting how big
this addressable population of users and
it winds up being when you build
something that you can actually use
um
and there's a lot of our customers where
like they require everyone to learn sql
basically like or like everyone who
comes in that's like a pre-record a nice
you know nice to have on the jd
and so if you if you think about that
and if you extrapolate that out i do
think there's going to be
that's going to be true for more and
more companies over time and
organizations over time you're going to
have more people coming into the
workforce with those skills and
interests
and um
uh
i'm really excited about building a
platform that can empower that entire
range of people not just the like
you know nominal data scientists you
know which which winds up kind of being
a small
high priesthood at a lot of places you
know and i go back to that that anecdote
i was sharing earlier about you know
there's only like three or four of us
who could do these things you know we
want to build a platform that's that's
much more inclusive than that
got it starting with the the publishing
analogy like the printing press of the
bible you know get the bible into the
hands of the common people right like
that's right the gospel of data right
yeah
it's uh the vernacular of uh yeah that's
that's an interesting uh analogy i've
not thought of that one before
you you can use that for free i mean
it's on me thank you no no one knows
that yeah i got that from you right
we're not live or anything that's good
um well so so the hex platform is really
compelling i've seen the tool um as i
mentioned the design is just awesome i
really respect what you guys have done
um i want to hear about some of the the
new features that you're most excited
about because
you know instead of just thinking of of
hacks as like a big giant notebook
collaborative notebook in the cloud um
that's sort of easy for everyone in your
team to like poke out and run and you
know log into and view and share and
and all those collaborative things
you're actually you've actually pushed
the paradigm in some really
interesting
um
implementation ways so i want to want to
hear about that and i i think you've
called some of this hex 2.0 um you know
tell us about some of the things that
you're most excited about in that
category
yeah yeah so
um
it's been it's been a really fun
this year especially i just think as the
product sort of as we built the
foundation out i've been able to go
pursue a lot of these big ideas that
we've we've had for a while and last
month we launched hex 2.0
which is had some pretty
fundamental reworks of some of the ways
that these workflows these workflows
operate um
i think the big one of the big tentpole
features there was um our new execution
model
um and so
i think for anyone familiar with
notebooks or these workflows um you know
they they've probably run into this
frustration and i think it's like best
uh
cat encapsulated by joel gruse is
infamous uh i don't like notebooks
and you know like as someone has used
notebooks for a long time i like love
notebooks i think they're great they're
really cool but i like you look at
joel's talk and then you like reflect on
your lived experience of using them and
you're like yeah he's right like that's
actually some really like like problems
in here and i think for us it was it's
been an interesting journey sort of both
embracing that notebook paradigm like
hey this is a really cool way to work
with data
along with like
also acknowledging that like well
there's a lot of room
for this to evolve and grow um and so in
hex 2.0 we introduced a new
dag based
reactive execution model and so to
unpack that a little bit it's
we parse out
the code in
a given project the sql in python in
each cell
and we are doing some analysis of the
code to understand the dependencies
between cells so
each cell sort of has a sense of
uh objects that return so if it's like a
query cell where you're writing sql it's
returning a data frame
uh python cells you know similarly can
return data frames as objects they can
also just return parameters or other
types of objects
and then we parse the code to understand
the dependencies and so that actually
forms a dag a directed asymptotic graph
which is obviously a concept that's very
common in our blog post actually about
hex 2.0 one thing i point out is like a
lot of people are familiar with
a dad-based reactive execution model
because of spreadsheets so going all the
way back to the spreadsheet stuff
spreadsheets operate with a reactive dag
like if i update cell a1 and i'm
referencing it in cell f5 like
that
there's a there's a reference it knows
you can't do circular references so it's
it's a
acyclic graph you know it's kind of it's
kind of funny how many people in the
world use a reactive dag based execution
model today in spreadsheets and so this
isn't necessarily like a new idea we
have it's but it's taking that paradigm
and applying it into
into this world and so
this execution model solves
i think the three big problems around
state and notebooks which is
reproducibility so when i update
something knowing what's going to update
knowing that it's going to update
reliably knowing that my logic is going
to rerun in the same way every time
interpretability
which is
i as a notebook user both for myself and
while collaborating it can be very hard
to understand what's going on like
especially the way people wind up
writing code in notebooks it's not
necessarily always like
really you know well organized into nice
functions or whatever like
and so by having this dag that you can
actually visualize and so in hex 2.0
actually have a graph ui
that you can you can inspect
it makes it really easy to actually
interpret and understand what is well
how it is my logic spot this cell
connects this cell connects to this cell
i can see the whole dependency tree it's
really really nice
and then performance and i think it's an
ironic thing that you know we talk about
and hex you can publish your work as a
data app that anyone can use
well the way we did that was okay cool
when you publish it and someone's using
it as an app will rerun the logic top to
bottom every time
and that helps solve that
reproducibility problem around like well
it's just going to run top to bottom and
so it's it's easy to understand what's
going to happen
but
it has a performance it's also more like
it's going to it's gonna run all your
logic every time so by doing it through
the dag
you're only rerunning downstream logic
that needs to rerun when you when you
update an upstream node and so it you
know it's a really great model for that
so again solves the problems with
reproducibility interpretability and
performance and this is great for
advanced users who have been using
notebooks for a long time like i've been
using notebooks for a long time this is
a better way for me to work with that
and that's really awesome but it's
really also great for this bigger
population of people that we've talked
about a few times that are like exactly
the people for whom
like they get a weird colonel thing or
they get you know dependency error and
the state weird state stuff that they
can't understand you exactly people for
whom like notebooks in that paradigm
will just drive them up the wall or
just discourage them and it's like a
barrier of entry to these workflows
generally like even if you can get a
local python environment and get a
jupyter notebook running like these are
the types of things that just make it
really really intimidating and so
this model being more interpretable and
approachable i think is really really
cool for that bigger population of users
um and something we're really excited
about
yeah that's awesome and what's the
response been like to this feature so
far
well great i mean
um
you know
we you know we launched it we we had the
blog post explaining it and i've gotten
just kind of a flood of of both people
like
really responding to the problem like
and even joel garuce i think tweeted
about it like you know like like you
know the patron saint of there's a lot
of problems with notebooks i think you
know it clearly resonated with people
who have felt that pain and i think did
you say this cool or
this is cool or the song what did he say
no no
um
i think for him it's cool to see i don't
want the words in his mouth but i i i
sense it's very cool for him to see
people taking the critiques he has
outlined and sort of doing something
with them and saying let's actually try
to address those in a in a really
forward way
um
and then i'm really proud of our team
the implementation of it is really cool
the technical level the way it actually
works and then the graph and the ui
around it i think is really sharp so i'm
i'm um the response has been great it's
well received by our users and um
the foundation for a lot of other stuff
we want to kind of do that's great very
cool um i also wanted to ask you about
this other feature that i read about
which is the the data frame
oh yeah
yeah that was that was new to me um how
does that work
that's a cool one um
so in a notebook traditionally uh
you
you always actually know but
traditionally it's really just all
python really
and um you can like write some sql if
you want to like query uh something in a
structured way or it's like okay i'm
like
roll my own like database connector you
know import sql alchemy and do that and
then like write a sql string and shove
it into this python call and it's like
it's really clumpy it's not great so
many months ago in hex we introduced
first class sql cells so it's a nice sql
it's basically a sql ide within a
notebook it's really awesome
that sql cell returns a data frame that
then you can use downstream and other
in your python
data frame sql kind of says well
we're going to treat every
data frame in the scope of a project as
a
effectively a table that can be queried
and so
the results of like a sql cell
are then actually available to be
queried by another sql cell so you can
write sql on sql which is sweet because
it's better you know you see a lot of
the sql queries people write and they
have these ctes so for people who write
sql it's like you know with as
statements where you're kind of like
creating these subtables and then and
then doing so
data frame sql sweet because you can
kind of unbundle that and actually like
treat each of those things that you
would previously have as a cte is it's
on query and then join things up
and you can also have data frames
created by python
uh also available so even if i'm doing
something in python or pandas you know
i'm creating a data frame
that's also available to be queried and
so we kind of treat every data frame in
the project is part of like a meta
database and so what that means is that
you can actually create a whole project
that's end to end sql which is what a
lot of our users do now or a whole
project that's end-to-end python or a
mix of the two and whatever you want and
so that kind of like flexibility is
really cool and it kind of abstracts
a lot of it away and combined with the
dag model too it's like
almost a very functional like node based
thing where it's like okay this cell
creates a data frame that can be queried
here and done here and um
it's very i think intuitive to a lot of
people especially those who are coming
to this not necessarily from like a
really deep data science long-term
notebook user background
yeah
and what about the implementation of a
feature like this how did she do that
yeah we are we actually looked at a
bunch of things uh over time and um one
of the things that really
sparked us was we've discovered a
project called duckdb which is a
in-memory olap data store and um it's
pretty cool it's it's uh they're
you know it's still pretty early they're
like version 0.3 or something like that
but
great team um we're actually
supporters of the ducktv foundation now
um and it was a really cool piece of
technology for us to be able to work
with and use
um to enable that so we were able to
take these data frames and use duckdb as
then like effectively to query the query
engine for those and it's it's very
postgres like syntax so it's pretty you
know pretty vanilla
uh as far as sql syntax goes yeah it's
really cool
very cool
um since we're talking about sort of the
the you know under the covers and the
product um
what's an example of a more daring
architectural decision that you'd say
you've made in building hex
few i think the bet on the hex 2.0 model
was kind of a big one
you know deciding that we wanted to walk
away even from some of the
some of the priests traditional precepts
around notebooks and how those work
um
you mean with the dag the execution the
dag yeah the dag execution model and
actually it was an interesting journey
because we actually tried a few
different implementations and i think
for us it was even
sort of believing that we could show a
better way to do this even if it was
different than how people might be used
to working and so one of the cool things
about hexa i think is that if you're an
existing notebook user like if you're
familiar with tools in the space like
hex will feel familiar and powerful but
then we open up these new ways of
thinking and we're working with that
thing with things and so
handily there's certain things that you
could do in python like a traditional
jupyter notebook that like won't work
with this execution model like there's
ways of like certain synthetics and
things that you know our parsing won't
properly do
and like
yeah okay well that's the trade-off we
might you know get pissed some people
off
like you're
but for us that felt worth it to to have
this better model um and so you know
there's trade-offs with all of those
things and then
i think there's some interesting
architectural things as well just in
terms of
the bigger platform how we're scaling
the compute and all of that um that's
probably a talk for another time but um
yeah there's a few big bets we've made
i'm really proud of that
got it
cool
um and
how would you say hex fits into a cloud
native world i mean it seems fairly
obvious to me um i i guess from knowing
a little bit about about the
the tool and the way it works but you
know talk to us about sort of the bigger
vision that that you might have there
yeah
well i'd say it's i'd say hex is
fundamentally built for the cloud native
world i mean it's it's cloud native in a
way and that it's it's hosted it's um
uh lives in the cloud
i think when you think about cloud
native there's probably a couple lenses
there there's like
cloud native in terms of like
collaboration which which kind of cloud
native just means like online and
collaborative right like
um and i think hex was built from day
one with that assumption of it's gonna
run in the cloud it's gonna be easy for
people to collaborate in the cloud in
that
way um it's very cloud native from that
aspect in the way that something like a
google docs or a figma or something you
know is cloud native
um
and then i also think there's a there's
another angle of this which is like
cloud native in terms of the way data
workflows are going you know you think
about
what does it look like to have a cloud
native data stack well it's you know
it's a data warehouse like snowflake
it's it's cloud native data processing
tools like 5chan or dbt and hex works
really well with all of those things
and also sort of assumes that people are
going to be working with data on that
scale at that cloud native
scale and so
um i think we're just scratching the
surface of what cloud you know cloud
native cloud first world looks like for
data and um hopefully we can make some
small contribution to that in our own
way of what that means
got it
great well um
we're almost out of time but i i want to
ask you a couple more questions before
we let you go back to to building all
that hex goodness
[Laughter]
um what's what's what's your bigger
vision for the company like what's your
thought on sort of where the product
heads and
um
where the company goes
next we have we have a lot of a lot of
ideas uh a lot of things a lot of things
on the road map on our mind i think one
of the hardest parts
is just you know it's just focusing it's
like picking up one of the few things we
want to go really invest in
um and there's always a tension i think
between building the like immediate
things people are asking for and then
stepping back to those bigger bets you
know no one really asked for hex 2.0 or
the dag execution model and the way we
built it
but people were asking for a lot of
other things that we felt like well
that's actually the real way to go
fulfill that or to solve those problems
and so there's a number of other things
like that on our minds of things we want
to go and do and invest in and and big
bets to go take
i think it all comes back to this
mission we have about empowering
everyone to do more with data together
should be you know how do you help
increase the access to
these workflows how do you help empower
more and more people to do amazing
things with data and how do you help
turn that into a more collaborative
exercise and again i feel like we're
just tip of the iceberg or whatever
metaphor scratching the surface whatever
truism you want to use about
um
about going and doing that and so
um you know we've got
we've got a lot of stuff we're excited
about and i think
even between now and the end of the year
i have a couple big things i'm excited
to get out the door
great
what surprised you most about working in
this community so far
surprised me most
um
i don't know i i don't know if it was
particularly surprising but i was
certainly
excited and grateful for how
warm and collaborative everyone is even
folks that we kind of maybe compete with
you know it's a crowded space everyone
kind of competes with each other at some
level like
it
it really feels very authentic and
everyone's just sort of just excited
about cool stuff and i
you know i talk with people all the time
that are even you know adjacent or
whatever and
it feels like we're at this moment in
data right now where there's such an
explosion of new ideas and things and
who you know some of these things will
work and become really big some of them
won't and you know that's that's all
kind of baked in the cake and i think
both within hex and then in the broader
community it feels like there's just a
lot of excitement and energy to just be
exploring and trying new things and it
feels very collaborative and so i'm very
grateful for that and um um he's gonna
do what i can to try to keep
keep that going
yeah that's great well you haven't even
been to a data council yet um because
we've only we've only met since you know
sort of the very early days of the
dynamic so
um yeah just a way
this is the whole
the whole sort of function behind data
council um you know not to be too
self-promotional but i'll i'll get a
word in edgewise anyway um to get the
community together
in austin uh it's gonna be awesome
there's so many amazing tool companies
that have like come out of that
that collaboration and um and that
community so couldn't be more excited to
support that exactly that sort of notion
of collaboration that you're touching on
i i'm excited about that and i think you
do a great job helping facilitate that
through the work you do including data
council uh which i'm excited i'll be
there in austin so anyone else who's
there awesome i would love to meet you
uh about to hang out we'd love to talk
about this stuff um and uh i'm really
looking forward to that yeah very cool
looking forward to having you there so
so barry we'll let you go um but i wanna
just before we do um
make sure that people know where how
they can try hacks um and how they can
reach you if they have questions or
comments um what what are the what are
the two best hooks there
yeah well hex tech is our uh internet
website uh that you can go visit and uh
and get access to the product
um
and then my email if you want to reach
out is pretty easy to guess it's barry
at hex.tag right
i'm occasionally active on twitter uh my
handle is
barrelled b-a-r-r-a-l-d but um email me
find me on twitter
and i'm pretty pretty reachable
uh for folks in the data world i want to
talk about this stuff i'm always always
down to chat so we loved it we'd love to
connect with anyone virtually or in
person now that such a thing is possible
again yeah great awesome well thanks for
that and thanks for joining us very it
was really great to have you here yeah
likewise this was fun thanks for hearing
me out i hope that wasn't too boring oh
so it was great great chat
i'll see you
see ya and to our to our audience um
thank you for tuning in want to remind
you that next week november 11th
we'll be talking with rick lammers from
orchest on data science pipelines so
don't forget to join us for our next dc
thursday next week
thanks again to everyone for listening
to barry again and we'll see